yeah a lot of people have written me
about this fart gate on hardball last
night there was an obvious fart and
Chris Matthews is calling it fake news
he says it was his cop running against
thee the the desk there's no [ __ ] way
I listen people are experts you tuned in
people are experts in sports and they're
on TV people are experts in the stock
market I'm an expert in farting I know
when it's a fart and this was a part it
was a fart it's not a cup and I can even
prove it I'll do an experiment how well
first listen to the tape Robin Chris so
far the evidence is uncontradicted that
the president used taxpayer dollars to
ask the Ukrainians to help him cheat an
election and the complaint that I've
heard from Republican that's a little
fashion-forward here's a mug the chef
the drunk cello mug as you can see and I
have a similar surface here to the desk
at MSNBC how do you know that because I
watched that show every night and it's a
sleek slick surface that's how I know
you don't know where that Cup was it
could have been sitting on a mat so look
this is what a cop sounds like on a
surface like that you hear that listen
Robin
you don't even know if it's the right
kind of mug yeah no because they have a
chalo mug on they say that's what a mug
sounds like your scientists pieces now
let's go back to the tape didn't use
taxpayer dollars to ask the Ukrainians
to help them cheat an election and the
complaint I've heard from Republicans
I'm a fart scholar I've studied farting
since I don't know college but you don't
have the exact material you can't sneak
a fart pass Howard Stern and what's with
all these shame and embarrassment stop
it do what I do make it part of the show
[Music]
you